today we are going to be giving you the
four one one on some things that are
going down for the e3 comfort a new dr.
mario game is going to be announced at
e3 I know you as dr. Mario are actually
working at a free clinic for the members
of Jersey Shore yet each level is one of
the members of Jersey Shore the last
level Snooki it's covered in viral I'll
have to be honest I cannot even fathom
trying to finish that board you know I
can't beat Snooki there's a new
Uncharted game coming out yeah it's
called pitfall oh they're releasing a
new Dragon Age at e3 they're totally
reverse engineering the whole system you
will be playing it in your mother's
basement with dice in a series of books
they can call it Dragon Age Dungeons &
Dragons age I've gotta beat the Balrog
there's a new Street Fighter game coming
I do it's a versus its Street Fighter
versus LittleBigPlanet to be fair though
this is the first time sack people have
showed up in a little Street Fighter
because I don't know if you remember and
bison he's got it he wears a cape I've
rated this game a sack of [ __ ] I read
this game to sex love we also found out
they're making a sequel to Red Dead
Redemption except this one is set
seventy years after Red Dead Redemption
in a city where you have to steal cars
it's called Grand Theft Auto one new
Grand Theft Auto coming out yeah
Grand Theft Auto Salt Lake you're a
Mormon in Utah well you basically go
door-to-door on a bicycle it's your only
vehicle I don't know why it's still
called Grand Theft Auto and you deliver
pamphlets and you got a partner that's
with you the whole time that dress is
exactly like you do but you pretend not
to be gay expect Sony to have a lot of
3d stuff at the booth I'm expecting the
announcement of Dead or Alive
beach-volleyball 3d except there's no
volleyball it's just you and 3d and
boobs all up in your [ __ ] it's the first
3d game ever that you have to play with
your pants off they're making another
God of War game mm-hmm but instead of
God of War it's all actually called god
of the harvest and you play Dionysus and
you just go around getting drunk with
centaurs yeah
hey you heard it here first
Oh